نقطه مع ضيفنا في هذه النافذه رئيس
الحكومه البلجيكيه رئيس وزراء بلجيكا
السيد الكساندر ديكرو اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
دكرو
السيده الكرو
كمل هاريس تحدثت عن الصين وقالت ان اي
مساهمه من الصين في دعم روسيا بالسلاح
سيمثل تقويضا للنظام الدولي الان اريد ان
اربط مع اخر اجتماع واحنا اصطدناك
التقطناك من اجتماعك الاخير بمسؤول علي
المستوى في الخارجيه الصينيه تحدثتم عن
ماذا بخصوص اوكرانيا وبخصوص العلاقات
الثنائيه بين بلجيكا والصين
لقد حظيت بفرصه التقاء بوزير الخارجيه
السابق الصيني والذي هو يتراس الوفد
الصيني لقد تحدثنا عن رغبتنا في الوصول
الى السلام والسلطات الصينيه تتفق مع هذا
الامر اذا الصين هو له علاقه بوقف
الاعتداء ووقف الاعتداء على كل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بلجيكا عانت كثيرا خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ونحن نعلم ان محادثات
السلام تحدث اذا كان هناك وحده اراضي
الاوكرانيه والتي يجب ان يتم احترامها
ولقد اشرت ان الصين بامكانها ان تلعب دورا
اساسيا لتوضح لموسكو بان الاعتداء لابد ان
يتوقف وان محادثات السلام ستحدث فقط عندما
نقوم باحترامي سلامه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
تجدد دائما دعم بلجيكا لي اوكرانيا لكن
بلجيكا الى الان ترفض تقديم
الدبابات الطائره المقاتله لاوكرانيا وفي
هذا انتم تختلفون عن مواقف الدول
الاوروبيه مثل جارتكم فرنسا جارتكم هولندا
وحتى المانيا لماذا
الكثير من الدعم العسكري والانسان كنا من
الدول الاولى التي فعلت ذلك اولا مدبابات
لدينا دبابات ولكن لدينا الكثير من
النقاشات المفصله التي خذناها مع اوكرانيا
بشان الاسلحه التي هي جيده بالنسبه لنا
لدينا خبرات في مجالات متعدده غير
موجوده اخرى ولقد تصلنا هذه الامور مع
اوكرانيا لكن لا نتواصل بشان هذا الموضوع
مع جهات اخرى لكن قررنا الاسبوع الماضي
توفير 92 مليون يورو من الدعم العسكري
مباشره الى اوكرانيا
طيب هذا بالنسبه للدعم العسكري هناك موضوع
اخر بالنسبه لموقف بلجيكا يبدو دعنا نقول
غريبا قليلا وهو ان بلجيكا ترفض مقاطعه
روسيا في موضوع تجاره
الالماس
يعني انتم مع العقوبات ولكن العقوبات لا
يجب ان تشمل تصدير الالماس الى الى روسيا
لماذا
[موسيقى]
الدماء لابد ان يتوقف ولقد لعبنا دورا
اساسيا في هذا الاطار لكن هذه التجاره لا
تاتي الى اوروبا وانما ت
ذهب الى دول تحترم العقوبات ما نشهده ان
هذه
الاماس
الروسي يباع في اوروبا يباع في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مع المفوضيه الاوروبيه
نحن نعمل على مقاربه دوليه لمقاطعه
وهذه المساله الوحيده التي ربما قد تنجح
نحن في بلجيكا نحن فعلا نعمل على البيع
بالجمله وسنعمل في الاسابيع القادمه من
اجل هذه المقاطعه حتى يتم الايفاء بذلك
حتى يكون هناك نظام تعقب يتم وضعه من اجل
العمل على ذلك مع المفوضه الاوروبيه هذه
الطريقه الوحيده لوقف هذه التجاره مع
روسيا ونحن فعلا فعلا سنعمل واثقون الناس
بتحقيق ذلك في الاشهر القادمه
نعم نعم في سياق مقاطعه روسيا هناك موضوع
الطاقه طبعا نعلم ان بلجيكا لا تعتمد على
روسيا في موضوع الطاقه اعتمادها الاكبر هو
على النرويج ولكن كيف ترى انت اختلاف
المواقف الاوروبيه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
حول موضوع مقاطعه الطاقه الغاز
هو انه اليوم الغاز الروسي الروسيه لم تعد
سلاحا اذا كان هذا الامر كذلك قبل فتره
ووضع اوروبا تحت الضغط لكن الاعتماديه على
الغاز الروسي والنفط الروسي قد تراجع بشكل
كبير جدا كان اربعين في المئه ووصل الى
مستويات اقل من 20 في المئه ولدينا
احتياطيات مهمه للمضي قدما فيما يخص فصل
الشتاء وانا متفائل لنصل الى مرحله يكون
فيها قطيعه مع الغاز الروسي وهذه المساله
هي جيده وهذا سيوقف التمويل بالنسبه لهذه
الحرب البربريه التي تجري في اوكرانيا
وهنا اريد ان اثمن الجهود التي تم بدلها
من قبل دول مثل المانيا لتحقيق هذه
الاهداف اقل من سنه واحده الطاقه الروسيه
اكرر لم تعد سلاح حرب وهذا انجاز كبير
بلجيكا كان لها موقد انساني جميل جدا في
الزلزال الذي ضرب مؤخرا تركيا وسوريا او
فكتم ارسلتم فرق انقاذ واغاثه وفنيين الى
تركيا
ونتساءل هل يمكن لهذا الموقف الانساني
الجميل ان يتطور الى موقف
سياسي داعم لتركيا في موضوع الانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي وماذا ايضا عن انضمام
السويد وفنلندا واللغط القائم حول ذلك
الامر
نريد ان نعبر عن تعازين لكل الاسر
والاشخاص
الذين توفوا في كل من تركيا وسوريا فعلا
هذا الامر هو يدمي قلبنا
انقاد وبحث وانما
ارسلنا وقمنا ببناء المستشفيات اشخاص
يعملون بعد انتهاء مهمه من يقومون بمهمه
البحث والالقاد طواقم طبيه ونحن سنعمل مع
بعضنا البعض من باعاده البناء بالنسبه
لهذه المناطق هذه من الامور التي لابد
نلعب دورا بشانها نحن كاتحاد الاوروبي مع
تركيا لقد عملنا عن كثب فيما يخص قضايا
تتعلق
وهذه المواضيع هي ليست مواضيع سهله وتعاون
تركيا كان مفتاحيا مهم بالنسبه لتركيا كما
هو الشان بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي
بالنسبه للخطط المستقبليه والانضمام
لاوروبا بامكاني ان اقول ان هذه المساله
كان الكثير من النقاش بشانها قبل عقد من
الزمن لكن اليوم لابد ان نرى ان هذه
النقاشات توقفت وبكالها فقط ان تمضي قدما
اذا كان هناك رغبه من قبل الطرفين ولنرى
نوع العلاقات التي تريد تركيا ان تكون
لديها بالاتحاد الاو
روبي
رئيس وزراء بلجيكا شكرا جزيلا لك